[Music]
so resident evil welcome to raccoon city
is the resident evil movie mulligan
after the paul w s anderson movies have
been wrapped up for a few years now now
it's time okay we're gonna reboot the
franchise because that's that's what
happens you know when something wraps up
in cinema it's like okay do we make a
sequel or a remake
what are we doing so resident evil
welcome to raccoon city is the telling
of resident evil 1 the game and resident
evil 2 the game crushed into one movie
which right there the signals the
warning lights start going off when i
hear that and even when i was watching
that it's hard enough adapting a video
game into a two-hour movie because
that's hours upon hours of game play and
story being crushed into two hours so
someone out there had the bright idea
like okay well that sounds hard enough
so let's take two video games and crush
it into one movie that's about an hour
and a half and right when this movie
started
and as it kept going i was like okay i'm
bored and you might be thinking you
would be right to think that you'd be
like make sense world building character
development patience jeremy but it
didn't feel like that at all it wasn't
building up the world it wasn't fleshing
out the characters in fact by the end of
this movie
i was met with the feeling of everything
i know about the characters i knew from
the game felt like this movie relied on
the video game doing the heavy lifting
of character development which sucks i
don't like it when movie adaptations of
video games do that you know like assume
that the audience hasn't played the game
like you look at arcane i haven't
reviewed arcane the league of legends
series yet but i will patience folks
it's coming give me time to gorge on
thanksgiving and a weekend to be in a
coma after that it's holiday calories it
doesn't count that's food law but one of
the things i love about arcane is it
doesn't rely on the video game to build
the world it assumes the audience has
never played the game before so it's
world building is done in the series its
character development is done in the
series that's how it should be done i
wasn't met with that feeling with this
resident evil movie which is funny that
it feels that way because then the movie
wants to put in for some extra credit
and gives you this claire and chris
redfield backstory where they were in
some
super shady orphanage and the movie
starts out with that and it seems to go
on forever it was probably three and a
half minutes it felt like 15. the point
is after this backstory when they were
kids then it starts out claire's in the
semi with the dude eating the burger and
he's i was like oh resident evil 2. so
why didn't the movie just start out here
i have no good reason even by the end of
the movie that whole backstory with the
orphanage thing could have been taken
out wouldn't have affected the movie at
all the characters in this movie are a
mix of generic characters they had on
screen so they can tick the box like
okay we technically had that character
from the game so it works and then you
had claire redfield who was the standout
and claire has always been a standout in
the resident evil series so i'm glad
she's the standout in the movie i
thought claire in here was actually well
done in terms of claire's a good job
movie you did claire well wesker
when when his name is dropped like hey
wesker i was like get the [ __ ] out of
here
you're serious for a second i thought he
was wesker's kid from resident evil 6 he
would have worked in that capacity
wesker in this movie is kind of like if
wesker was in his late 20s but he
couldn't leave the college life behind
you know he couldn't leave the frat
behind he was still growing i mean
leon's still rookie cop in here but why
have rookie cop who steps up to take on
hordes of the undead with claire
redfield when you can have rookie cop be
the butt of all the jokes and you might
as well have been called gomer pyle in
here he really is that incompetent and
the guy's just he's not good at being a
cop at a point that go to the armory and
he doesn't know how to work a shotgun i
was like okay did you work at a fast
food restaurant and then you just found
a dead cop and you put on his uniform
you're like all right sweet i'm gonna
play cop now cause that's about how cop
you're coming across there's even this
one scene where leon and claire are
bonding he's like bet you're kind of
wondering how someone like me became a
cop she was like yeah kind of and he was
like me too
i was like oh that's that's the end of
the story
fair enough won't lie i was kind of
hoping for some answers but if you don't
have them
how can i expect you to give them to me
and other than the fact that the setup
of this movie the first hour is boring
as hell when the zombies start coming on
in the mansion i was like okay
it's kicking on let's do it and it
started to feel like that resident evil
movie i was really hoping for back in
the 90s and then okay the movie ends it
has this fair amount of things that are
from the game that make this feel like a
better representation of resident evil
at least a more accurate one when you
line up the resident evil movies that
came before it and this one if you look
at some of the sets the sets are equal
parts impressive and baffling like when
you get into the mansion i was like yeah
that's
it's the mansion you know it's that big
gaudy mansion you want to see more
accurate than the previous movie did it
so i dig that raccoon police department
rpd you're looking at the lobby you're
like it has a big statue in the
background you're like this is bold from
the game i appreciate that but then
there are scenes where their police
chief is breaking down okay you guys are
gonna go to the mansion and they're in
this room that doesn't look like it's
part of the same building this office
looks like it's one of those mobile
offices you see it used car lots or
construction sites or something and no
not in that way of like well it's a big
building certain parts of the building
are gonna feel different no it just it
felt like they had two completely
different filming locations they were
like oh it doesn't really feel like it
matches
doesn't matter the script in this movie
too so far i've just kind of compared it
to the game and how it is as a resident
evil movie this
the script a lot of the character
dialogue in here comes across as lazy in
which i don't know if the actors were
given free agency
to improv or maybe the script had a
certain phrase and maybe the director
was like i mean you can phrase it
however you want but on more than a few
occasions you had just a bunch of
characters interjecting the word [ __ ] in
between every other word one character
that i can think of was really
surprising he's going oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh
oh [ __ ] my cat got your tongue dude
sometimes less is more it just came
across like high school drama class
improv in which the teacher was like
okay i don't care what you say as long
as it's the first thing that comes to
your mind do you have a bunch of high
school students going oh [ __ ] i
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] i mean not that i care about curse
word what do i give a [ __ ] you know me
the word [ __ ] doesn't offend me lazy
scripts do there were a couple scenes in
here that were cool it's like someone
you ever do that you ever sit around
like oh someone should put that in a
horror movie or someone should put that
in an action movie that'd be a sweet
shot moments like that happen in here
you know one with chris redfield and
he's in the dark trying to fight zombies
his only light source is the blast from
the muzzle i thought that was pretty
neat and you know stylish i dug it
that's the thing about this movie it has
moments of imagination under a blanket
of straight to dvd and when you see
things in here that you're like dude
that's from the game and i want that to
be awesome but the game just did it
better i feel like it's more telling of
the times we live in you know when
resident evil came out resident evil 2
came out you're playing this game on
playstation the polygons you know
they're playstation 1 polygons so the
thought of seeing this in full cinematic
glory that was just an amazing thought
something that i was waiting baited
breath i really wanted to see that and
turns out i finally did see that in the
resident evil 2 remake that came out
we're in the phase of gaming now where
games like the resident evil 2 remake
give you that resident evil cinematic
experience that a movie could only hope
to live up to but also gives you an
amazing gameplay experience that a video
game should get in that i don't need a
resident evil movie like i felt i did
back in the 90s it's almost a guarantee
that it'll fall short of whatever the
video games can conjure these days and
as seen i feel that's how it went down
the characters had [ __ ] development the
pacing was off and i can't say i'm gonna
ever watch this movie again i'd rather
just play the resident evil 2 remake i'm
just not going to remember it in t-minus
one day yep already forgot all right so
resident evil welcome to raccoon city
have you seen it what did you think
about it
are you gonna see it i saw one trailer
for this movie in my entire life and
that was when i was in the theater there
to watch something else forgot what
anyhow i feel like the marketing for
this movie sucked but it is in theaters
now or what's a video game from the 90s
that you would like to see an adaptation
happen legacy of kane i know me too
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you